.
>> PHIL, WE'LL LET YOU GO.
ENJOY THAT HIGH SCHOOL BAND
BEHIND YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS SENATOR
ELIZABETH WARREN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE SECOND QUARTER GDP REPORT
SHOWS THAT THE ECONOMY DID
SHRINK BUT LESS SO THAN
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT FROM APRIL TO
JUNE THIS YEAR.
THE GDP SHRANK 0.6%, NOT 0.9%,
WHICH A JULY ESTIMATE SHOWED.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS ALSO VERY LOW.
BUT AMERICANS ARE STILL FACING
HIGH PRICES BECAUSE OF
INFLATION.
SO HOW DO DEMOCRATS CAMPAIGN ON
AN ECONOMY THAT IS SUCH A MIXED
BAG?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S ABOUT ARE
WE TRYING TO HEAD THIS THING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION?
YOU KNOW, LOOK, WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF REASONS THAT PRICES ARE
DRIVEN UP FOR FAMILIES.
AND WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HIGH
PRICES FOR FAMILIES.
BUT PART OF IT IS STILL COVID
THAT CAUSED THE SHUTDOWNS AROUND
THE WORLD.
WE STILL GOT SUPPLY CHAIN
PROBLEMS.
WE STILL HAVE A WAR IN UKRAINE
THAT DRIVES UP ENERGY PRICES,
AND FRANKLY, WE STILL HAVE GIANT
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE
ENGAGING IN PRICE GOUGING.
ALL OF THOSE KEEP PUSHING THOSE
PRICES UP.
NOW, THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE
THAT PRICES ARE COMING DOWN.
THE BEST PART IS, AS YOU POINT
OUT, UNEMPLOYMENT IS LOW,
PAYCHECKS ARE COMING IN.
BUT THE MAIN PART AS I SEE IT,
IS THE DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING TO
GET THIS ECONOMY AND KEEP THIS
ECONOMY ON TRACK FOR EVERYBODY.
PUT THE REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE,
AND LET THEM DO ANOTHER $2
TRILLION TAX BREAK FOR
BILLIONAIRES AND GIANT
CORPORATIONS.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
CHARGE, WHAT WE'RE DOING INSTEAD
IS WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS
ECONOMY WORK FOR EVERYONE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW WITH LOWER
UNEMPLOYMENT AND WITH MORE MONEY
BACK IN PEOPLE'S POCKETS ON
THINGS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO PUT A
CAP ON THE COST OF INSULIN AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS FOR PEOPLE ON
MEDICARE.
THOSE ARE THE DIRECTIONS WE WANT
TO GO IN.
AND CANCELING STUDENT LOAN DEBT
IS PART OF THAT.
TRYING TO HELP OUT WORKING
FAMILIES.
>> SO JOE BIDEN YESTERDAY
ANNOUNCED A DECISION TO CANCEL
UP TO $10,000 OF STUDENT DEBT
FOR MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
UP TO $20,000 OF DEBT FOR PELL
GRANT RECIPIENTS.
COLLEAGUES OF YOURS FACING TOUGH
RE-ELECTION RACES DON'T SEEM
HAPPY WITH THE DECISION.
SENATOR CORTEZ SAYS IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE ROOT PROBLEMS.
CONGRESSMAN JARED GOLDEN SAID
THIS IS OUT OF TOUCH.
SENATOR MICHAEL BEN IT OF
COLORADO SAID THE ADMINISTRATION
SHOULD HAVE PROPOSED A WAY TO
PAY FOR THIS PLAN.
ARE THEY WRONG?
>> THE WAY I SEE IT IS THAT THIS
IS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BRINGING THE FULL
FORCE OF OUR GOVERNMENT TO HELP
WORKING PEOPLE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT 42% OF THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
DO NOT HAVE A COLLEGE DIPLOMA.
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO TRIED BUT
FOLKS WHO WENT TO BEAUTY SCHOOL,
FOLKS WHO MAY HAVE TRIED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THEY ARE
NOT EARNING ENOUGH TO COVER
THEIR STUDENT LOAN DEBT BURDENS.
THE WAY THE PRESIDENT HAS SET
THIS UP IS TO CONCENTRATE THE
HELP AMONG THOSE WHO NEED IT
MOST.
BY DOING THE PELL RECIPIENTS WHO
ARE THE LARGEST BENEFICIARIES,
IT'S PEOPLE WHOSE INCOME, FAMILY
INCOMES FOR 95% OF THEM, IS
BELOW $60,000.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WORKING
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE VETERANS, THEY ARE
MOMMAS AND DADDIES TRYING TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL.
THEY'RE FIRST GENERATION PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET INTO COLLEGE.
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS REACHING OUT AND
TRYING TO HELP.
WORKING PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING.
AND AS DEMOCRATS, THAT'S WHAT WE
OUGHT TO BE DOING.
>> IS THIS ONE-TIME STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS, JUST A BAND AID ON
THE REAL UNDERLYING ISSUE HERE,
WHICH IS THE SKYROCKETING COST
OF COLLEGE TUITION?
>> WELL, IT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE.
AND THAT IS THE BUILT-UP STUDENT
LOAN DEBT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT MADE ANOTHER
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY, THAT IS
HOW PEOPLE WILL PAY FOR COLLEGE
GOING FORWARD.
AND HE'S GOING TO CHANGE THE
INCOME DETERMINED REPAYMENT PLAN
SO THAT NOBODY HAS TO GO THROUGH
DEBT HELL TO TRY TO GET AN
EDUCATION IF THEY WENT AFFORD TO
WRITE A CHECK FOR IT.
BUT THE FUN PART IS ABSOLUTELY
ABOUT HOLDING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SO HAVE OTHER DEMOCRATS.
WE WANT TO SEE COLLEGES HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME.
WE PUT ADDITIONAL MONEY INTO
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
I'VE GOT A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT IS ALMOST MADE IT THROUGH.
THAT DEMANDS MORE TRANSPARENCY
FROM COLLEGES SO THAT THE COSTS
ARE CLEARER UP FRONT, SO THAT
THEY HAVE TO POST INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW LONG IT TAKES PEOPLE
TO GRADUATE ON AVERAGE.
HOW MANY GRADUATE AND HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY MAKE WHEN THEY GET
OUT.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THEY NEED TO DO TO GET THE COST
OF COLLEGE UNDER CONTROL.
BUT IT'S THREE DIFFERENT PARTS
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK ON.
I START TODAY BY CELEBRATING THE
PART THAT SAYS FOR LITERALLY 20
MILLION HARDWORKING PEOPLE, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY STUDENT LOAN
DEBT ANY MORE, AND FOR ANOTHER
23 MILLION, YOU'VE GOT SOME
RELIEF ON THAT DEBT.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE LIFE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO NOW WILL BE ABLE TO
START A SMALL BUSINESS, START A
FAMILY, SAVE UP MONEY TO BUY A
HOME.
GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY OVERALL.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FAIRNESS ARGUMENT THAT I'VE
HEARD FROM REPUBLICANS, AND FROM
DEMOCRATS, WHICH IS WHAT ABOUT
ALL THOSE AMERICANS THAT PAID
THEIR DEBTS AND TOOK SECOND,
THIRD JOBS OR DECIDED TO NOT GO
TO THE PRICIEST SCHOOL, ISN'T
THIS UNFAIR TO THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK OF THE
FAIRNESS ARGUMENT THIS WAY, UMM,
I WENT TO COLLEGE.
MY DADDY WAS A JANITOR.
I WENT TO COLLEGE WHEN IT COST
$50 A SEMESTER.
WHEN A PART-TIME JOB WOULD COVER
THE COST OF COLLEGE TUITION.
IT DOESN'T DO THAT ANY MORE.
AND THAT IS A REAL GENERATIONAL
FAIRNESS PROBLEM.
THAT OPPORTUNITY IS JUST NOT OUT
THERE.
LOOK AT IT THIS WAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT PORTION OF HARVARD
UNDERGRADS HAVE TO BORROW MONEY?
2%.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT PORTION OF
STATE UNDERGRAD STUDENTS HAVE TO
BORROW MONEY?
ABOUT 50%.
AND WHAT PORTION OF HBCU GRADS
HAVE TO BORROW MONEY TO MAKE IT
THROUGH COLLEGE?
80%.
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
AMERICA, IT'S WORKING GREAT IF
YOU'RE BORN INTO A FAMILY THAT
IS WELL-TO-DO.
BUT IT'S NOT WORKING GREAT FOR
THE REST OF THE FOLKS.
PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE, THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET AN EDUCATION.
THESE ARE THE FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING TWO JOBS IN NURSING
HOMES, FOLKS THAT ARE AIR
CONDITIONING AND REPAIR PAYMENT
NANCE, PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING ON
TABLES, AND THEY CAN'T COVER THE
RENT, PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE, AND
STILL MANAGE AN AVERAGE $400 A
MONTH, TO BE ABLE TO PAY STUDENT
LOAN DEBT.
WE NEED TO GET THAT DEBT BURDEN
OFF THEIR BACKS.
WE NEED TO SET UP AN INVESTMENT
IN OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
SO THEY DON'T COST AN ARM AND A
LEG.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
KID IN THE FUTURE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO GO TO COLLEGE, HAS TO
GO THROUGH DEBT HELL AND
MORTGAGE THEIR FUTURE, ALL THE
WAY TO THE END OF THEIR LIVES IN
ORDER TO TRY TO GET